[Music]
rome
at its peak in the second century a.d
the empire dominated
five million square kilometers from the
atlantic coast to iberia
all the way to the persian gulf
and at its heart was the eternal city
cramped bustling filled with the colors
sounds
smells and fluids of a thousand cultures
poured into one marketplaces saw fine
silks from the far east
traded alongside artisan chainmail from
gaul
and jars full of blood red wine from the
roman heartland
free men scholars and slaves of every
creed in colour rubbed shoulders in the
streets
the hub of a giant multicultural empire
the perfect place for disease to
proliferate
the ultimate super spreader
city
so it was in the summer of 166 a.d
that famed roman physician galen found
himself battling an enemy much deadlier
than any barbarian horde limping home
from distant parthia in the east
three legions had returned with a cruel
gift from those far-off lands
their skin covered with sores and
pustules
they burned with fever and the entire
camp stank of loosened bowels
death hung in the air
the plague quickly spread it struck
indiscriminately
affecting rome's citizens equally with
cruel indifference to position or
stature
galen tried to treat the afflicted some
recovered their skin
permanently scarred and their bodies
broken many
weren't so lucky he studied the dead and
dying
he probed their wounds searching for
some common factor some hidden
cause but even he the most accomplished
physician in the city
failed to find the agent of such
destruction
the plague continued for years and from
the empire's glorious center
outward it spread entire cities and
towns
wilting under its attack three years
after its arrival in rome
the emperor lucius ferris finally
succumbed
and some 11 years later his co-ruler
marcus aurelius also died with the very
same
fever and blistered skin galen witnessed
it all
but was helpless to stop its seemingly
limitless spread
by 180 a.d 70 million souls had died
totaling more than a quarter of the
roman empire's entire
population
[Music]
galen was a visionary of his age but he
was trapped in the second century
and could do little more than document
the pandemic as it unfolded
had he possessed the scientific
understanding and equipment of a 20th
century doctor
he could have identified the sickness as
smallpox
this vicious disease was only conquered
in 1980 some eighteen
hundred years after the devastating
antanine plague
it was caused by a virus
a mere particle less than one hundredth
of the width of a human hair
this of course was not the first time
viruses had changed the course of
history
and it wouldn't be the last had galen
possessed the understanding of our 21st
century scientists he could have peered
into the genes of his fellow citizens to
see the legacy
of viruses written into our very dna
for what galen did not know what he
could not have known
was that his parthian gift had been
evolving
hand in hand with the life it ravaged
for billions
of years potentially since before the
very beginning
of life itself
[Music]
to understand the origins of the
enigmatic viruses galen battled 1800
years ago
we must first unravel what exactly his
silent enemy was
and the first to even get close to this
mystery was the russian botanist
dmitry ivanovsky at the time
a plant disease was threatening one of
the most valuable luxury exports of
north and south america
tobacco plants in an effort to find the
cause dimitri had taken the leaves of
diseased plants and crushed them
reducing them to a liquid extract he
then passed this extract through a solid
porcelain filter
with pores so small that even the
smallest known bacterium couldn't
squeeze through
but to ivanovsky's surprise this
processed filtered extract
still had undiminished potential to
infect new tobacco plants
whatever was causing the tobacco mosaic
disease it was smaller
than bacteria what on earth could be so
small he thought
and still contain the essence of such
coordinated
destruction
[Music]
it would take another 40 years of
scientific advancement
before the virus was actually seen for
the very first time
if we could shrink our bodies down a
million fold so that we were just a
micrometer tall
we would be able to see with our naked
eyes the tiny
viral particles responsible for such
terrible diseases
as smallpox hepatitis and aids
there are about 100 million more viruses
on earth than there are stars
in the universe each less than a
thousandth of a millimeter in size
they are denizens of a rich and varied
nano cosmos
each miniscule particle is intricately
crafted as distinct in form and function
as the macro size life forms they infect
in shape alone there are tiny rods
smoothed and spiked spheres
angular dodecahedra and upright spidered
forms that bear more resemblance to
interplanetary probes than any life form
we know they range in size from a mere
20 nanometers
to relative giants as large as a
bacterium
giant pythoviruses cruise this
nanocosmos
leviathans searching for amoeba to
infect ebola
is a grotesque knotted snake locked in a
permanent rectus of torture
while tiny bacteriophages seem the most
complex of all
with features that resemble legs a head
and a deadly
injecting syringe
within these alien structures are
genetic molecules
similar in construction to our own
double-stranded dna or single-stranded
rna
but shorter simpler more naked and
exposed
these are unlike the cells that make up
the bodies of every living thing on
earth
they are little more than a hard protein
shell around a fragment of dna
and each one is unique containing its
own assortment of genes that tailor it
to a particular host
whether human animal plant or microbe
a virus floating freely through the air
is inert
and the virus unsuited to our body's
chemistry is harmless
only when a viral particle encounters
its preferred host will it spring into
action
with compatible chemistry it will be
able to insert its genetic molecule
fragment
into an unwitting cell to hijack its
living processes
to reproduce itself some simply use the
protein machinery suspended in the
cell's cytoplasm to blindly reprint the
viruses genes for packaging and shipment
back out of the cell
but others are more tenacious these
so-called retroviruses insert
their dna fragment directly into the dna
of their host
in reality the viral nanocosmos is made
visible only with the most cutting-edge
technology
and modern scientists are still working
to understand how these seemingly simple
agents can bring about such
suffering and how they can be conquered
so we have seen the enemy the first step
to understanding its origins but even
now
a fundamental question remains
unanswered
what is a virus
and are they even alive
answering this question cools into doubt
our understanding of what separates life
from non-life on earth and elsewhere in
the cosmos
classic definitions are taught in
schools that living things all have the
independent ability to move
grow reproduce sense their surroundings
seek nutrients extract
energy from them and excrete waste by
this scheme
viruses are certainly not alive they do
not grow
they don't have any metabolic processes
and they are utterly reliant on a host
for reproduction
they are parasites as lifeless as dust
without the spark of life stolen from
other living things
there are of course exceptions though
as always
[Music]
in england in 1992 a new kind of microbe
was found in a cooling tower
for ten years scientists thought it was
a kind of bacteria because of its large
size
but high resolution imaging revealed
that it was in fact
a virus of unprecedented size and
complexity
a leviathan floating amongst minnows
nearly 10
times as large as its cousins
they named it mimivirus because it
mimicked living bacteria so closely
these mimiviruses contained more than
just a dna fragment
they also had enzymes and other
machinery inside their shells
not quite enough independent living but
much more than we had previously thought
inert viruses capable of processing
although the vast majority of viruses
may not be classically alive they are
still undoubtedly of
life the fact that they have the same
genetic molecule
and the same biochemistry that makes
them seamlessly compatible with living
cells
must elevate them above the inanimate
world even if they don't fully deserve a
place
in the animated one some scientists have
suggested that we revise our
classification of life
purely to include these potent organic
nanoparticles
perhaps they deserve their own branch on
the tree of life rooted at the base
next to the origin of the domains of
bacteria and eukaryotes
but one thing is clear to understand the
viruses place among life on earth
we need to try and trace their history
through geological
time to know what they are we have to
understand
how and when they began
but finding the unimaginably small among
the unimaginably ancient
is a problem modern scientists are only
just beginning to tackle
and the solution may not lie in the
rocks beneath our feet
but within our very dna
at the southeastern tip of england the
green fields of kent
meet the blue of the english channel in
a flash of white
the white cliffs of dover tower over the
modern day port
they are a welcome sight to british
travelers returning from the south
and were immortalized in wartime song as
a beacon of hope for better things to
come
and yet these cliffs might just be the
remnant of a series of deadly pandemics
that took place 65 million years ago
they are made of chalk a form of
limestone or calcium carbonate
made up of tiny grains as fine as powder
compacted
into solid rock every single one of
these grains
is a fossil a tiny mineralized scale
that once formed part of a spherical
shell
around a single celled alga called a
coca lithophore
when magnified hundreds of times these
individual cochleaths
are intricate discs of surprising
complexity
combined in their many trillions the
discs are the sole constituent of cliffs
more than 100 meters tall these hopeful
pure
white cliffs are nothing more than an
immense
graveyard the remnant of death on a
spectacular scale
coccolithophores protected in their
calcium carbonate spheres are green
algae that float in the surface waters
of the oceans
soaking up the sun to power
photosynthesis inside their cells
but coccolithophores like all life on
earth
are not immune to viral infection
there is a virus tiny in comparison to
the already minuscule algal cells
that can penetrate the protective sphere
and penetrate
the photosynthesizing cell the boneyards
left behind by these algal pandemics are
mere sprinklings of coccolith scales
among other sediments that wash over the
ocean floor
but at the end of the cretaceous period
some 70 million years ago
coccolith graveyards accumulated over
tens to hundreds of thousands of years
algae bloomed and died bloomed and died
over and over again
thickening the layer of chalk mud until
it was some half a kilometer thick
and this is still the case millions of
years later
viruses are constant adversaries of
every living thing and we are doomed to
grapple with them in the future
as we have done in the distant past
but viruses are capable of more
than destruction and our shared history
is far more complex
the constant threat of viral infection
has in fact been a major driver
of evolution
when an infecting virus damages cells
and brings about disease
then a species survival depends on it
being able to adapt
to weather the storm or eject the
offending particle
in this way the immune system has
evolved as a defense in animals
and been incrementally improved over
millions of years
but this only works for so long in
response to the immune defense
viruses themselves evolve and adapt it
is a military arms race where it's small
with both sides improving their advances
until the very nature of the warfare
evolves
but there is another unexpected role
that viruses have to play in the
evolution of life
these tiny inanimate particles behave
like genetic messengers between
otherwise unrelated organisms
produced in one hijacked cell a virus
will be released into the world where it
can infect
another possibly belonging to an
entirely different species
the genes that the viruses carry are
shared between the infected
giving them all access to unique traits
without having to evolve them from
scratch without their own
genetic code the retroviruses which
reproduce by inserting their genes into
the dna of their host cells
inadvertently gift the host with the
instructions
for new features which may just turn out
to be beneficial
scientists think that a retrovirus that
infected early mammals gave them the
instructions for making a new kind of
protein
which eventually led to the creation of
the placenta
during pregnancy
in 1990 the human genome project was an
outrageous and ambitious effort by
scientists all over the world
to read the encyclopedia of human dna
it was no small task they were trying to
determine the order of some 3 billion
base pairs
or characters in the instruction manual
of life
had these been written on actual pages
they would have filled several
hundred volumes but just 13 years after
it began
after revolutions in genetic techniques
and computing analysis
the human genome project was complete
but the work was only just beginning
although they now had the ordered
characters of dna in hand
it would take another international and
multi-disciplinary effort to interpret
what these characters meant
the results trickled in over the early
years of the 21st century
one of the most shocking revelations was
that just a tiny
fraction four percent of dna
actually corresponded to the genes that
determine our features
the rest was something of a mystery for
a long time
termed junk dna now we think a lot of it
controls when the gene is turned on or
off
recently cutting edge science has
revealed that some eight percent of the
total
originated in viruses
specifically retroviruses that smuggle
their genes into the unknowing host
normally the retroviral redraft only
happens in body cells
and can be cloned and copied when the
host is alive but disappears when the
infected organism
dies but if a retrovirus happens upon a
sex cell
an egg or a sperm destined for a new
generation then its code
is carried forward to be preserved ever
more within the genes of the descendants
there's just a minuscule chance of this
happening but over millions of years
the retroviral inventory in our cells
has gradually grown
and now there is twice as much virus in
us
then there is us
this could be the key to tracing viruses
back to the very beginning
[Music]
paleontologists probe ancient rocks for
the fossil remnants of living things and
microfossils of tiny bacteria have been
found dating to some three and a half
billion years ago
but there is no prospect of finding
viral fossils preserved in rocks
it is hard enough for viruses to be
isolated and imaged accurately in modern
samples
let alone those crushed and cooked
inside rocks ravaged by time
so searching for viral fossils becomes a
subject instead
for geneticists who compare through time
with the molecules of life
by sequencing the genomes of humans
animals plants and bacteria
geneticists can trace the history of
viral infections through time
if a viral sequence is shared by an
entire group then it's likely
that the group's ancestor was the one
who was infected first
recently a group of scientists
identified a molecular fossil in our
genome that was also shared by about 25
other mammals
including aardvarks marmosets and bats
but this viral fossil seemed to be
randomly scattered among the different
types of mammals
it was as notable in its absence as in
its presence
this told an intriguing story of not one
ancient infection
but of many a series of viral epidemics
that cross species back and forth
infecting unsuspecting animals for some
15 million years
although we don't know for sure what the
virus did to these animals what is
certain
is that its genes are now forever part
of our story
just as viral genes seem to have been a
part of the story of life
perhaps since life itself has been
around
and their origins are as indistinct as
the origin of life
so in search of the first virus
it helps to try and consider how
viruses came to be how can something
obtain
some of the features of life but never
all of them
[Music]
in 2002 just a few short years after the
human genome project published the
encyclopedia of life for the first time
eckhardt vimer and his team at stony
brook university in new york
achieved something that had previously
only been the stuff of science fiction
or conspiracy they created a virus
from scratch like dr frankenstein they
used the advanced and seemingly
magical genetic techniques that the
genome project had pioneered
to stitch together dna sections in the
precise order
to make a simple monster a polio virus
related to the wild polio that crippled
adults and children in the middle of the
last century
something like vemma's breakthrough must
have happened naturally in the
biological world
sometime in the history of life the
result
is the viral nanocosmos we see today and
the record of their dna
in our cells only the first viruses must
have arisen without
the 21st century tools at a geneticist's
disposal
as for how this viral shadow life can
arise naturally
scientists still aren't sure but there
are
a couple of theories
the first is of progressive virus
evolution
there is a strange phenomenon in most
eukaryotic cells
in which small sections of genes can
move jumping from one area in the genome
to another
it is as if the first page in a book
could occasionally jump from the
beginning
to the end to somewhere in the middle if
these sections of dna acquired the
ability to move in and out of a cell
too with the help of a little protein
protection then they would have had the
same transmissible qualities
of a virus from moving between the pages
of a single book
these progressive genome fragments could
choose any location
in an entire library this explanation
best fits the characteristics of
retroviruses
which have this compatibility with their
host genomes and the unique ability to
rewrite their dna
but not all viruses work in this way
a second possible theory is one of
regression
where living cells gradually lose their
metabolic machinery
leaving only the basic genes to be
passed on to future generations
by dispensing with their intercellular
proteins the regressive cell
loses its independence it must rely on
another life form to supply the energy
and processing power
for reproduction it becomes a parasite
we know this has happened with bacteria
in the past the bacterial cells that
were engulfed to become mitochondria and
chloroplasts
inside early eukaryotic cells are now so
diminished
that they could no longer survive on
their own
could this have been the root of viruses
too
looking at the giant mima viruses with
basic proteins alongside the genetic
molecule
it is easy to imagine them as having
once been alive
and independent the scant evidence left
within most viruses means there's little
else to decide between the progressive
and regressive origin perhaps they are
both correct
with different types of viruses arising
independently in different ways
throughout history but
there is another intriguing possibility
viruses are singly adapted for one of
the most fundamental features
of life that of reproduction
and we know that the very first cells
which originated in the archaean oceans
some three and a half billion years ago
must have been capable of this
too even before the first cells there
must have been a genetic molecule
capable of storing and replicating
genetic information for future
generations
and the iterative evolution of
biological
metabolism a replicating molecule
without a biological metabolism
was probably one of the earliest steps
in the evolution
of life from non-life and today we find
replicating molecules without a
biological metabolism
all around us in viruses
in theories of the origin of life a
single stranded genetic rna molecule
could have acted as its own replication
machinery
it is no great leap to imagine single
stranded rna viruses
behaving the same way in the absence
of living cells to hijack and so
in this virus first hypothesis the
viruses didn't break free of life
or regress from more advanced living
cells
but preceded life itself
they could have been a vital step in the
origin of all life on earth
once true life as we understand it
surrounded itself with a cell and built
a self-sustaining metabolism
then the viral branch on the tree of
life diverged
the earliest viruses themselves evolved
building protective protein shells and
devising more efficient ways of
replicating themselves
using machinery borrowed from the other
branch of life
in this way true life and the viral
shadow life
were destined to be eternally
intertwined
viruses there before the first cells and
then
alongside the first cells ready to
hijack
and infect it's an enticing theory
but we may never know for certain an
unimaginable gulf of time lies between
the modern nanocosmos and the earliest
virus
but the clues that we can find from
galen's view of the unstoppable roman
plague
to the geneticists viral fossils written
into our very dna
suggest that viral infection is
and perhaps always has been a
fundamental part
of life on earth
[Music]
you've been watching the entire history
of the earth like and subscribe and
leave a comment to tell us what you
think
and we'll see you next time